thank you for joining us
tonight in our second installation
of the great book
about our prophet and messenger muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
his days his time his actions his words
his era
this era of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
is the most significant era
of the history of this great earth
the history of the entirety of the world
and humanity
from the beginning of adam alaihissalam
all the way to the end of time the
greatest
era was
the era of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
when we look at the quran and how allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala drew
our attention to this era
we notice that allah subhanahu wa allah
swears
in the quran by things that he wishes to
draw
our attention to with regards to the
magnitude of these
objects or these things allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala swears by himself
swears by the stars and the moon and the
sun
and he is also sworn by the life of the
prophet
he is the only prophet the only human
being
in all of the quran that allah
i swear by your life
and this is in order to draw our
attention to the great magnitude of the
life
of the prophet muhammed
he swears by time itself
the scholars of islam have differed with
regards to what is meant
by time is it meant is what is meant
by the elephant lamb here well
some say what is meant is i swear by
this era meaning the era in which this
verse was revealed
and that is the lifetime and era of the
prophet muhammad
and so it's important for us to
understand
and learn and most importantly
follow the way and tradition
of the prophet muhammad and that's what
this book is about
this book is completely dedicated to
this subject
we are going to begin now with actually
going through the book
and reading it the book is extremely
dense it's been
comprised into about
usually five volumes and we mentioned
that
throughout time many
volumes have been independently
released and published as independent
books such as the medicine of the
prophet
the medicine of the prophet that many
people are
accustomed to seeing reading it's a
very popular book it's
authored by ibn kayim it is actually the
fourth volume of
zed and
so we are going to begin with this
book
however we are going to summarize it a
lot
we are not going to obviously go through
every single page and every
single statement and many
or a lot of the statements are
issues of linguistic and great
linguistics and grammar and eloquence
and things which
are not well served when translated into
english and so we are going to go with a
very summarized
approach very concise
and our brevity
and abridgement of this book will
revolve around the
essence of the book and that is the
prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
begins this book with discussing
the issue or the topic of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
choosing of his creation
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala is the only
creator
and then he subhanahu wa just as he is
the only creator
he is the only one rightful to choose
to elevate of his creation to
favoritize of his creation whom he
chooses subhanahu
then speaks about what the criteria
for such a choice is that yes allah
chooses whom he wills
yet his will is dictated subhanahu by
his wisdom
and we will discuss that after this
goes into discussing
the importance and the necessity
of every human being to know the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
and his sunnah and his way and his
tradition
this is very important these are the
three
main topics we are going to discuss
today insha'allah or i should say
tonight he begins with a verse
which is in surat al-qasas it is the
68th
verse of surat al-qasas
[Silence]
in this verse that which translates to
and and in this verse
he is addressing the prophet muhammad
he says to him that which means and your
lord
he is the one who creates whatever he
chooses to create
whatever he wills to create and he
likewise
chooses and selects of
this creation what he chooses it is not
for they
meaning the creation of allah to have a
portion
in making this decision and this choice
rather above
and high above is allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala of any notion
of polytheism or anything that they
ascribe unto he which is
unbefitting
based on this verse that just as allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is the only creator
likewise he is the only one
who has the right to choose of that
creation
what will be elevated
what will be given a greater precedence
and importance
than others this is a choice which is
completely to the discretion
of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala now this
verse in order for us to
totally understand it this verse was
revealed as a response
to the antagonists of the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam many of them had said
why
why if if you are truly a messenger
why is god why is allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala choosing you
why didn't he choose someone of greater
societal status why
wasn't it fulan or fulan why wasn't it
this guy or that guy or this tribe or
that tribe
and allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says in
response to this
and your lord is the one who creates
that which he wills and he is the one
who chooses it is to his discretion not
to theirs
they have no portion of that choice
and those decisions which are made just
as he is the only one who has created
he is the only one rightful to choose
subhanahu
this is the 124 verse of
the sixth chapter of the quran allah
subhanahu wa
says that which translates to and allah
is better knowing and all knowledgeable
of where he should place his message
meaning in the heart of which man and
also
on the tongue of which man who will be
the messenger
and this verse as well was a response to
some of the antagonists of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam who said
why isn't it that just every single one
of us
receives a message why doesn't every one
of us receive
the message as he
[Arabic recitation]
receives the message
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said in
response to this
allah knows best where to place his
message
also in this spirit in surah
verse number 31
says
[Silence]
which translates to and they addressing
the antagonists of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
wasallam his opponents and they say
why wasn't this quran if it is from
allah
revealed to another man of the great two
communities
someone of higher societal
status allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
rhetorically asks and says
are they the ones to whom
discretion belongs with regards to
how the mercy of your lord will be
distributed
is that to their discretion are they the
ones who have the right to
decide where the mercy of your lord
shall be placed
he says subhanahu wa'ta'ala we are the
ones
who have decided and divided up
their bounty in the life of this world
and it is we who raise them in stations
and we have elevated some over others
and so these verses articulate to us
that
true the choice of discretion as to who
will receive a message
who is the one who will receive this
enlightenment
this belongs only to allah subhanahu wa
this is a choice reserved for allah as
he is the only one who has created
he is the only one who has right to
articulate to that creation what he
chooses
and choose of them whomever he wills
and so allah subhanahu wa ta'ala also
alludes to the fact that for us to
try to intervene
or interfere with that choice
which is solely to the discretion of
allah for us to assume
a position of interference with the
distribution of that message is a type
of shirk
for us to say it shouldn't have been
this way
rather it should have been this way
allah should have done it this way
or allah should have chosen this person
as opposed to this one this is a type of
and that is why allah concludes this
verse by saying
far above and high is allah
from all that which they ascribe to him
of
subhanahu so
he goes now to describe to us
what the criteria of that choice is
the criteria of that choice is the
wisdom of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
allah's wisdom allah's knowledge that is
what
his will is dictated by subhana he does
not have to ask anyone
he does not have to seek anyone's
approval
he does not have to appease
anyone rather this discretion is to
allah
and he subhanahu wa is the one who
chooses
and that choice is based on his wisdom
and his knowledge subhanahu wata'ala
and it is of course not based on their
knowledge
and honestly something we have to
understand about
this world we have to understand
something about
our choices as human beings
i want everybody to really think with me
about his or her choices
i can think about my choices and i can
say
with certainty that i disagree with
myself
last week what i believed or what i
thought about a particular issue
whatever issue it is i very well
may disagree with it this week and
more so last year i disagree with things
that i did or
said or positions that i may have held
or choices that i made last year
and this year being that i have grown
that i have attained more wisdom more
knowledge more information
more experience i disagree with myself
how much more so does my adult self
disagree with my adolescent self very
much so things with that were a big deal
when i was a little kid
have no have no importance or
significance today
to my adult self to my mature self
and so it's important for us to
understand that
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is not subject
to this trial and error he is not
subject to mistakes
his knowledge is perfect and
encompassing
our knowledge is deficient it's preceded
by
ignorance and our knowledge is followed
by forgetfulness and much of our
knowledge
is